Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Enes Ertürk.
Ich bin der für Sie zuständige Arzt in dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute ein annames Gespräch durchführen.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufschreiben.
Ist das Ordnung für Sie?
Ja.
Super.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maria Lindemann.
Maria Lindemann.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Der Vorname Maria M R I A.
Lindemann L I N D I M A N N.
Lindemann.
Okay.
Frau Lindemann.
Wie heißen Sie?
58.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. August 1964.
16. August.
Wie bitte?
August 1964.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
64 kg.
Alles klar.
Frau Lindemann.
Was fühlst Sie zu uns?
Was kann ich von Ihnen sehen?
Zirka zwei Tagen fühle ich mich nicht wohl.
Zwei Tage.
Ich habe keinen Appetit.
Er ist übel.
Ich habe zweimal erbrochen.
Dann habe ich Schmerzen im Bauch.
Okay.
Seit zwei Tagen fühlen Sie technisch voll.
Wir haben zweimal Erbrochen.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ja.
Können Sie den Ort der Schmerz genau beschreiben?
Ja, das ist mehr so oben im Bauch.
Oberbauch.
Sie leiden unter Oberbauchschmerzen.
Oberbauch und so in der Mitte und auch mehr rechts.
Okay.
Wie sind die Beschwerden aufgetreten?
Wir haben die Schmerzen begonnen.
Z.B. für sich oder langsam?
Ja, eher langsam.
Langsam.
Okay.
Frau Lindemann.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie zum Beispiel dumpf, stehend, brennend oder sehend?
Also, Sie sind, denke ich, mehr so dumpf.
Mhm.
Aber Sie wechseln.
Also, mal sind Sie stark und dann gehen Sie wieder etwas zurück
und dann kommen Sie wieder.
Ach so.
Wie eine Welle.
Okay.
Sie sind die Schmerzen vorübergehend.
Ja.
Also, Sie sind mal, mal sind Sie mittelstark
und dann sind Sie wieder ganz stark
und dann werden Sie wieder eben mittelstark.
Also, es wechselt.
Okay.
Willen für mich, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Und kommen die Schmerzen als Abhaken
oder sind die Schmerzen immer da?
Also, eigentlich sind Sie immer da,
aber dann werden Sie stärker
und dann werden Sie immer da.
Ja, danke.
Aber Sie sind immer da.
Mhm, immer da.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10?
1 bedeutet sehr leicht.
10 bedeutet sehr stark Schmerz.
Ja, ich würde sagen zwischen 5 bis 7.
5 bis 7.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihnen übel ist.
Ja.
Ich würde Sie fragen, wenn Ihnen übel war,
mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Ja, ich habe 2 Beide.
2 Beide.
Okay.
Und wie haben Sie...
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Willen für mich.
Und generalen Schmerzen,
sind Sie irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, Sie sind meist im Oberbauch.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, es zieht auch so ein bisschen
in die rechte Schulter.
In der rechten Schulter.
Aber nicht so viel,
da meistens im Bauch.
Mhm, okay.
Das verstehe ich.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Okay, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser
für die Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel Essen, Trinken und so weiter?
Ich habe kaum etwas gegessen und etwas getrunken
in den letzten Stunden getrunken,
aber gegessen, ich habe keinen Appetit.
Mhm, okay.
Wenn Sie etwas Essen haben,
haben Sie Beschwerden genommen?
Kann ich nicht sagen,
weil ich fast nichts gegessen habe.
Okay.
Wenn Sie etwas Essen haben,
haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Oder treten die Bauchschmerzen auf?
Ja, weil ich habe ja nichts gegessen.
Seitdem ich das habe,
ich habe etwas getrunken.
Ich habe ein bisschen Tee getrunken,
ein bisschen Mineralwasser,
aber auch sehr wenig,
weil ich befürchte, dass es dann schlimmer wird.
Mhm, okay.
Und dann gibt es noch etwas,
das die Schmerzen lendet
und die Schmerzen sind noch schlimmer.
Außer Essen.
Wenn ich ganz ruhig auf dem Rücken liege
und die Knie, die Beine etwas anziehe,
dann ist es eine gewisse Erleichterung.
Aber bewegen und so kann ich mich nicht gut.
Ich liege lieber auf dem Sofa.
Mhm, okay.
Und dann habe ich dich verstanden,
wenn Sie Ihre Körperhaltung verändern,
dann ist es vielleicht etwas Schlecht,
aber ich fühle mich auch zu schlapp.
Ich will lieber liegen.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Und Frau Lindermann,
fühle Sie sich pipplich?
Ja, ich habe schon ein bisschen
mit der Körperhaltung,
aber ich habe auch etwas Schmerzen.
Ich habe auch etwas Schmerzen.
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Schüttelfrost
seit einigen Stunden jetzt
und habe den Temperaturfieber gemessen im Mund.
Das war 38,5.
38,5.
Okay.
Haben Sie gegen den Fieber etwas eingenommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sie leiden unter Schüttelfrost
und schwitzen Sie tagsüber oder nachts über
oder leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe aber die letzte Nacht sehr schlecht geschlafen.
Schmerzen.
Aber normal habe ich keine Nachtschweiß.
Aber lässt Sie nach,
haben Sie schlecht geschlafen und dann?
Ich habe schlecht geschlafen, aber nicht mehr geschwitzt.
Okay.
Wegen Schmerzen haben Sie nicht gut geschlafen, oder?
Ja, wegen der Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit zugenommen oder abgenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht immer gehalten in den letzten Jahren.
Okay.
Träten,
träten beim Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Schwierigkeiten auf?
Also ich habe normalerweise eine regelmäßige Stuhlgang,
aber jetzt, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich relativ wenig Stuhlgang
und der ist ganz weiß, ganz hell.
Das ist hell, hellfällig, ja?
Ja.
Also, haben Sie Verstoffung?
Oder?
Seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich kaum Stuhlgang,
aber ich habe natürlich auch wenig gegessen.
Normalerweise habe ich regelmäßig Stuhlgang, normalerweise.
Okay.
Die Farbe des Stuhlgangs, des Stuhls, hat sich verändert, ja?
Sie haben gesagt?
Sie sind ziemlich hell.
Fühlen Sie sich in der letzten Zeit müde, als ungewöhnliches oder mehr müde?
Normalerweise nicht, bis vor zwei Tagen, als das anfing.
Seitdem fühle ich mich schlapp und müde, aber vorher habe ich mich gut gefühlt.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Lindermann.
Fällt Ihnen in diesem Zusammenhang noch etwas ein, das wichtig sein könnte?
Oder haben Sie noch andere Beschwerde?
Ich habe noch andere Krankheiten, aber nicht andere Akutebeschwerden.
Ich habe diese Akutenbeschwerden, habe ich geschildert,
mit den Bauchschmerzen und mit dem Fieber,
mit den Stuhlgangs, mit den Stuhlgangs,
mit dem Fieber und das Gleiche.
Okay, ich komme gleich.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich war bei der Vorsorgeuntersuchung beim Hausarzt vor einem halben Jahr,
der sagte, die Impfungen sind alle aktuell.
Gut gemacht.
Das freut mich.
Okay, Frau Lindermann.
Lindermann.
Okay, haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Die letzte Nacht war schlecht, aber sonst kann ich gut schlafen.
Gut zu schlafen.
Okay, haben Sie alle, sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unterträglichkeiten bekannt?
Allergien nicht, aber ich habe eine Milchzuckerunverträglichkeit.
Milchzucker.
Okay, womit ersätzt sich 뭔가 Untervertschigher toolbox?
Ich habe dann wahrscheinlich, wenn ich zu viel Milchzucker
es hatte,...​
Ich habe Blährungen mit Unterbauchschmerzen, auch im Alltäglichstadsdurchfall,
aber das habe ich ganz gut im Griff.
Ich habe eine gewisse Di purplein Halte
und manchmal Raktasetabletten nehme.
Das klingt sehr gut. Und ich würde Sie jetzt fragen, ob Sie in der letzten Zeit Milchprodukt
gegessen oder getrunken? Nicht mehr als sonst. Also keine besonderen.
Okay. Okay, alles klar. Okay. Frau Lindemann, rauchen Sie?
Nein, mich rauchen nicht.
Super. Nicht rauchen. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nicht regelmäßig. Vielleicht einmal in der Woche, am Wochenende, ein Glas Wein.
Einmal Proboho, ein Glas Wein.
Okay. Und darf ich Sie fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Drogen haben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Gut. Okay. Jetzt würde ich Sie nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen. Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen,
die zum Beispiel Herzkrankheiten, Bluthoffdruck, Diabetes Melutus.
Ich habe einen erhöhten Augendruck.
Augendruck.
Seit fünf Jahren. Ich nehme regelmäßig Tropfen für ein Augentropfen, aber ich war jetzt so aufgeregt,
ich habe die Tropfen zu Hause vergessen. Ich vergesse den Namen immer wieder.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich kann ihn nachliefern.
Dann habe ich noch einen erhöhten Blutdruck seit zehn Jahren.
Ja, dann nehme ich Tabletten.
Seit wann leiden Sie?
Zehn Jahre.
Seit wann leiden Sie erhöhte Augendruck?
Fünf Jahre.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen noch andere Vorerkrankungen bekannt?
Nein, erhöhte Augendruck, erhöhte Blutdruck und nicht Zucker.
Frau Lindermann, dann würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja.
Als Kind Mandel.
Mandelentzeichnung?
Ja.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde ich an der Schilddröse operiert, weil die Schilddröse zu groß war
und auch Knoten hatte.
Okay.
War die Knoten gutartig oder beurteilt?
Die waren gutartig. Die wurde ich besucht, war gutartig
und seitdem muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Okay.
Würde die Schilddröse total entfernt?
Nein, ein kleiner Rest ist wohl stehen, der Arzt mir gesagt.
Aber ich muss deswegen regelmäßig Tablette nehmen.
Wer ist Medikament?
Ich nehme Ältiroxin.
Und Ältiroxin 75.
75.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Und für den Blutdruck nehme ich auch Tabletten ein.
Ja, genau.
Ich nehme Bisoprolol 5.
Eine Tablette morgens und eine abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch Ramipril 5.
Eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Wie viele Milligramm nehmen Sie bisoprolol?
Bisoprolol steht fünf dahinter.
Morgensabends, dann bin ich 50 Gramm morgens und morgens eins
und abends halbte.
Ein halb, ein halb.
Okay.
Und nun möchte ich Sie nach Ihrer Familienvorgeschichte fragen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, mein Vater ist 88 Jahre alt.
Der hat ein sehr schwaches Herz.
Moran leidet er.
Er hat einen schwachen Herz.
Und er hat auch noch einen Alterszucker.
Und die Mutter, sie hat ziemlich brüchige Knochen.
Er hatte schon häufiger Knochenbrüche.
Und hatte die 86 Jahre alt.
Und als sie 60 Jahre alt war, da hatte sie eine Geilenoperation
wegen Geilensteinen.
Und ja.
Keine Operation, ich glaube.
Okay.
Gab es Päle von Krept in der Familie?
Nein, bin ich bekannt.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie noch andere regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, wegen Milchzucker habe ich gesagt, lehme ich manchmal Laktase-Tabletten.
Aber nicht immer.
Bei Bedarfs?
Ja.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Lindemann.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin von Beruf Briefträgerin.
Briefträgerin?
Bei der Post, ich trage Briefer.
Okay, arbeiten Sie im Moment?
Ja, normalerweise arbeite ich.
Aber jetzt seit zwei Tagen geht es mir nicht gut.
Da kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Haben Sie krank gemacht?
Ja, ich habe gestern den Hausarzt angerufen.
Der hat gesagt, wenn es mir nicht besser geht,
sollte ich heute in seine Praxis kommen.
Aber es geht mir jetzt so schlecht,
dass ich gleich in die Klinik gekommen bin.
Okay.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage.
Haben Sie Probleme auf Ihre Arbeit, die Sie belasten?
Nein.
Es ist anstrengender Beruf.
Bei Wind und Wetter muss ich rausgehen und die Briefe austragen.
Aber ich finde das interessant.
Aber es ist nicht für mich kein Stress.
Okay, gut.
Sehen Sie verheiratet?
Ja, mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, 30 und 33 Jahre alt.
Und die Kinder sind gesund.
Super, Sie haben zwei Kinder.
Zwei Kinder, ja.
Ich habe auch noch zwei Geschwister.
Ja, und die sind gesund.
Eine Schwester, die ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Die hatte vor einem Jahr eine Bauspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Sie hatte auch Galensteine, die irgendwie den Gang verstopft haben.
Und deswegen hatte sie dann eine Bauspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Andere?
Ja, und der Bruder, der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Okay.
Ihre Schwester leidet unter Bauspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Ja, und der Bruder, der hat hohe Blutdruck.
Okay.
Ihre Schwester leidet unter Bauspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Ja, und der Bruder, der hat hohe Blutdruck.
Und der Bruder, der hat hohe Blutdruck.
Das war vor einem Jahr, hatte sie.
Ja, hat geliebt.
Musste dann operiert werden.
An der Galenblase wurde ihr die Galenblase entfernt,
weil da viele Steine drin waren.
Okay.
Okay, so.
Herr Lindermann.
Ich glaube,
alle wichtigen Informationen gesammelt,
haben Sie noch Fragen oder gibt es jetzt etwas,
das Sie mir sagen möchten?
Ja, ich frage mich, was kann ich haben,
dass es mir so schlecht geht?
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Nun würde ich Sie über den weiteren Schritt informieren.
Erstmal, Sie sollten hier bleiben,
bis wir die Diagnose bestätigen
und alles andere ausschließen können.
Und danach möchte ich Sie
Ihnen ökopällische Untersuchungen
und dann Ihnen Blutapp nehmen
und Röntgenaufnahme möchte ich auch.
Und danach, ich möchte Bauch
in Ihrem Bauch führen.
Je nach Befund kann ich Ihnen sagen,
worunter Sie leiten.
Und danach besprechen wir wieder.
Wo können wir es machen?
Ja, gut.
Danke Ihnen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Haben Sie gelb sucht?
Das habe ich vergessen zu fragen.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass ich so ein bisschen meine Haut empfindlicher ist
seit einigen Stunden.
Ich habe mich so ein bisschen wie juckreiziert.
Ich muss mich häufig kratzen.
Aber gelb sucht habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Wo sieht man die gelb sucht?
Im Augen.
Im Augen, in der Haut.
Vielleicht haben wir das.
Vielleicht kann das der Doktor bei der Untersuchung gleich sehen.
Ja.
Erschuldigung, ist die Urin Farbe?
Der Urin ist eher dunkel.
Aha.
Haben noch andere Fragen gelingen?
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerde früher?
Oder ist diese Beschwerde erst Episode?
Das ist ganz neu.
Was habe ich noch nie gehabt?
Danke.
Können wir Arsatzgebirge anfangen?
Ja.
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Mein Oberarzt.
Mein Name ist Enes.
Wenn wir Zeit hätten, würde ich einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Hab ich.
Es geht um Maria Lindermann, die 58 Jahre alt, 1,68 m groß, 64 kg schwer sei.
Sie hat sich bei uns seit zwei Tagen,
mit einer bestehenden,
bestehenden und
probendierenen Oberbauchschmerzen
vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen seien
wellent abordatet.
und strahlten in die rechte Schulter aus.
Die Schmerzen seien in Belemförmige und strumpf und strahlten in die rechte Schulter aus.
Sie haben zwei Mal Erbrochen.
Wie sah das Erbrochene aus?
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Das Erbrochene war gelb schleimig?
Gelb schleimig.
Der Patient zufolge liegt die Schmerzintensität auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10 bei 5 bis 7.
5 bis 7, okay.
Und die Patientin berichtete, dass sie unter Inapätenz leidet und sie haben kein Luft mehr etwas zu essen.
Weil wenn sie das essen oder die Schmerzen verschlimmern, nicht beim Essen.
Könntest du sich.
Die Patientin leidet unter Inapätenz?
Unter Inapätenz.
Ja.
Gibt es Veränderungen, Auffälligkeiten beim Stuhlgang und beim Wasserlassen?
Sie fügte hinzu, dass die üren dunkel geworden sei.
Und der Stuhlgang ziemlich hell geworden sei.
Die Stuhlfarbe auffallend zu.
Die Farbe des Stuhls ziemlich hell geworden sei.
Also die Patientin stellte sich vor wegen seit 2 Tagen bestehender abdomineller Beschwerden.
Im Epigastrium mit Ausstrahlung in die rechte Schulter.
Der Schmerz ist wellenförmig.
Schauer S5-7.
Gut.
Und?
Ja.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Vorgeschichte?
Und außerdem leidet sie unter Schüttefrost.
Ja.
Und Fieber, sie habe selbst das Fieber 38,5 Celsius gemessen.
Es bestehen febrile Temperaturen bis 38,5, oral gemessen.
Oral gemessen, ja.
Okay.
Und an Vererkrankungen leidet sie unter Glucklaukom.
Und auch Glucklaukom?
Ja, seit 5 Jahren.
Um, ja.
Und dagegen nehmen sie einen Augentropfen.
Ja, ein Augentropfenpräparat, das sie nicht benennen kann.
Ja, die nicht benennen kann, ja.
Gibt es Anerkrankungen?
Ja, sie leidet auch an Acryl-Hypertoni seit 10 Jahren.
Und dagegen nehmen sie Bisoprolol, 5 Milligramm, Morgens und Abends.
Und Ramipril, 5 Milligramm, Morgens und Abends, 1 halb.
Okay.
Sonstige Erkrankungen?
Und auch sie haben Unverträglichkeiten gegen Mistzucker und Laktose.
Also eine Laktose-Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, eine Laktose-Unverträglichkeit und die Unverträglichkeit äußere sich mit Durchschwahl,
die Diauer und Abdominalgie.
Ja, oder Meteorismus?
Meteorismus.
Okay.
Gibt es Voroperationen?
Ja, und als Kind, ich hab nicht, okay egal,
bei der, bei der Patienten, würde bei der Patientin sein,
parzell Tröedectomie, Tröedectomie vor 5 Jahren und ja vor 5 Jahren durchgeführt worden.
Ja, wegen Stromanodosa?
Ja, wegen Gutartike.
Vor 5 Jahren erfolgte eine parzielle Tröedectomie.
Tröedectomie, durchgeführt worden.
Und um an Odosa?
Nehmt die Patientin, die...
Ich regelnehme die Patientin, die auf 15, 25 Milligramm Morgens.
75, ja.
Geht es noch weitere Operationen bei der Patientin?
Also ja, als sie Kind war,
in der Kindheit, in der Kindheit,
in der Kindheit, würde sie Tröedectomie operieren.
Ja, so wurde sie Tröedectomiert.
Ja, in der Kindheit erfolgte eine Tröedectomie.
Gibt es Abfälligkeiten in der Familienfolge?
Ja, in der Familienfolgeschichte, in der Familienamnese,
fanden sich bei...
Ich herrschte in Sufisien,
oder schwere Herz.
Bei wem, bei wem herzten?
Ein Herz in Sufisien
und altes Zucker bei dem Vater.
Bei dem Vater.
Lebt der Vater noch?
Ja, die Eltern leben noch weiter.
Okay.
Und an Brüche geknöschen,
ich weiß nicht,
Mutter leidet an frakturierender Osteoporose.
Frakturierend, fraktur, frakturierende Osteoporose.
Okay, die Mutter leidet an frakturierende Osteoporose.
Und die Mutter würde Kulistik tomieren.
Ja, die Mutter wurde Kulistik tomiert,
wegen Galenstein.
Wegen Cholelytiasis.
Ja, und die Schwester,
vor einem Jahr,
die Schwester habe vor einem Jahr
an Pankreatitis gelitten.
Ja.
Und die Ursache der Pankreatitis?
Und Ursache des Cholelytiasis,
wegen Cholelytiasis.
Und deswegen würde sie Kulistik tomieren.
Okay, also es besteht eine gewisse familiäre Konstellation
bezüglich Cholelytiasis,
sowohl bei der Schwester als auch bei der Mutter.
Genau.
Okay.
Und der Bruder leidet an Arterilehipatone.
Okay, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die anonystische Angaben deuten auf
Akkulitiasis hin.
Akkulitiasis, ja.
Alternativ kommen
die Ursache der Pankreatitis
und die Cholodokolitiasis.
Ja, infrage.
Ursache Sturdi, die Pankreatitis.
Also bei der Konstellation,
wie die Patientin berichtet,
der Stuhl sei auffallend hell.
Er wurde dunkel.
Ist man eventuell an einer Choledokolitiasis denken?
Ja, genau, dafür, ja.
Und vielleicht sogar dann auch mit einer Begleitpankreatitis,
die sich entwickeln kann?
Ja, genau.
Die Patientin muss nüchtern bleiben.
Genau.
Und sie muss sich nicht mehr zu sich nehmen,
weder trinken.
Ja, in dieser Zeit müssen wir die Flüssigkeit verabreichen.
Die Flüssigkeit zuvor verabreichen.
Und danach möchte ich,
erst mal, ich werde die Patientin stattfindereaufnehmen
und ihnen einen Blutab nehmen
und brauche Personografie.
Eine Oberbrauchsonografie?
Aber brauche ich Personografie durchführen.
Und ich möchte auch IKGF verschreiben,
damit ich ein Generepektor ausschließen kann.
Ich sollte man immer im Rahmen der Aufnahmediagnostik machen.
Ja, klar.
Gut.
Okay, ja.
Was mir aufgefallen ist bei der Anamneseerhebung,
da sollten Sie ein bisschen darauf achten.
Dann wählen Sie manchmal mit Ihrem Kugelschreiber
in den Mund, ins Gesicht
oder schauen dann oft zur Seite.
Versuchen Sie, Blickkontakt zu halten.
Als Patientin.
Versuchen Sie nicht zu sehr,
oder die Hand nicht vor den Mund zu nehmen.
Das möglichst nicht machen.
Und Sie ließen sich ein bisschen
von der systematischen Anamnese ablenken.
Als ich gesagt habe,
ja, ich habe erhöhten Augenbrück.
Okay, ich habe erhöhten Blutbrück.
Da sollten Sie sofort nachfragen,
ich habe eine Brücke gebaut,
ich nehme auch noch andere Medikamente.
Bei hohem Blutbrück sagen,
wie lange, seit wann haben Sie den
und nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente ein.
Ich würde es sofort immer machen,
weil sonst wird das vergessen.
Das finde ich wichtig.
Gut.
Ich habe gesagt,
ich habe zwei Mal erbrochen.
Fragen Sie sofort nach, wie sah das
Erbrochene aus?
Das haben Sie nicht gefragt,
das kann ja auch blutig sein.
Oder schwarz.
Dann wird es ja schon ein bisschen,
denkt man, was ist da vielleicht eine Blutung?
Sofort nachfragen,
können Sie das Erbrochene beschreiben.
Dass die Patientin dann beschreibt,
das war gelb oder das war schwarz,
oder das war weiß wie.
Dass Sie da sofort sagen, ja, mit dem Stuhlgang auch sagen,
ist der Stuhlgang auffällig verfärbt
oder hat der Stuhlgang eine normale Farbe?
Das würde ich immer so als Nachfrage machen.
Das ist hilfreich.
Ich denke, ich habe Sie dann versucht,
auch medizinische Fachbegriffe zu beizubringen.
Denken Sie daran, dass Sie nicht sagen,
Bauchschmerzen gehen würden,
obarzt.
Sie sagen, abdominelle Beschwerden
im Oberbauch überwiegend im Epigastrium
und rechter Oberbauch mit Ausstrahlung
auch in die rechte Schulter.
Das ist ein Schmerz,
das ist ein Schmerz,
das ist ein Schmerz, der Schmerz wird
als Wellenförmig beschrieben.
Er ist dumpf, vielleicht.
Das kann man ja ruhig allgemein sagen.
Aber wichtig ist dann nochmal,
dass Sie dringend brüchige Knochen
in der Schmerz, die die Mutter leidet,
in der Vorgeschichte unter Frakturen,
bedingt durch Osteoporose.
Das ist ja die Erschilderung der Patientin.
Dass Sie das sagen.
Choli dochu, oder Choli litiasis.
Eventuell Choli dochu litiasis.
Das war bei der Schwester eine Begleitpankreatitis.
Diese familiäre Auffälligkeit,
die Schwester hatte mit 60 Jahren,
hatte also auch die Mutter mit 60 Jahren.
Die Schwester ist jetzt, die Patientin ist 58,
da muss man schon mal daran denken,
dass das vielleicht, das haben wir ja sehr häufig,
dass da eine Häufung an Gallenstein leiden, da ist.
Also versuchen Sie in aller Ruhe
das System beizubehalten.
Wenn Erbrochen geschildert wird,
dann muss man sagen, wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Wenn jemand sagt hoher Blutdruck zu fragen,
seit wann und nehmen Sie etwas ein,
dann haben Sie sofort das abgehandelt.
Weil sonst vergessen Sie das, dann fragt der Oberarzt,
ja, was für Medikamente nimmt denn die Patientin?
Und dann müssen Sie leider sagen, das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Das wäre nicht so gut.
Gut.
Ich muss daran denken, nicht zu sehr die Hand ins Gesicht.
Ich habe jetzt ganz viel gesagt zu Ihnen,
aber das ist mir nur aufgefallen.
Ja, aber trainieren Sie weiter
und ich hoffe, dass Sie auch bald
Ihren Prüfungstermin bekommen.
Gut.